WE WILL CALL TO ORDER THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES AND
ENERGY --
FOR THURSDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH OR
CALL THE ROLL.
HOLDEN HERE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
GEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK MOSTLY HERE REYES
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER FLORES YOU
APPROACH TO SO THAT WE CAN HEAR
YOUR BILL AB --
NINETEEN FOURTEEN JUST WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THIS
YEAR BONUS.
IT A LEADING US IN OUR LAST AS
ART COMMITTEE SECRETARY --
SHE IS TAKEN A NEW POSITION SO
WE GET THE GREAT ONE STRAIN TO
MAY GET PICKED OFF FROM US BUT
WE WANT TO APPRECIATE HER GREAT
WORK -- AND
SHOULD WE HAVE ANOTHER MEETING
WHICH I BELIEVE WE WILL.
BUT IT WILL BE DEFERRED KIND OF
MEETING I WANTED.
TO AT LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
APPRECIATION YOUR GREAT WORK.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE TO BUILD THAT
PROMOTES PUBLIC SAFETY SO WELL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED YOU
CAN MAKE A BRIEF STATEMENT.
THE MILITARY FEW I MAKE A
CLOSING STATEMENT WILL TAKE AT
WORK WERE GOOD I JUST RESPECT
LAST WEEK I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
--
LET'S A WE HAVE A MOTION TO
APPROVE CENTER PASSED.
I'M SO SORRY.
YES SO LET'S LET'S EXPERTS HAVE
ARE WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY
VALERIE TRABALHOS --
THANK YOU COMMITTEE ASPERA VOTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS BRED BARROW
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS NATIONAL
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION UNITED CONTRACTORS
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE A PONY PIPING
INDUSTRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VERY TO I WILL NOW TURN TO SEE
IF THEY'RE ANY GOOD.
SUPPORTED WITNESSES GOOD MORNING
ISRAEL SALAS WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY IN
SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING MIKE MONEY GOING
TO BE AFTER THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SANTA.
I WAS THERE ANY --
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO HAS
OPPOSITION TO THIS THIS BILL.
SEEING.
OUR ABOUT TO TO USE FLOOR.
BECAUSE MY CLASSROOM I DON'T
THINK YOU CARRY ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
AB NINETEEN FOURTEEN DO PASSED
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI AYE TRICITY
AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TING.
BILLS OUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE RESEARCHER
APPRECIATED MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER QUIRK WILL HEAR YOUR
BILL.
TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX THERE'S A
MOTION.
FOR ADOPTION OF YOUR BILL IT'S
BEEN SECOND OKAY.
I'LL JUST TO THE STATE THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL WHICH IS TO
SET UP AN ACCOUNT [inaudible]
WE'RE UTILITIES.
CAN PUT DOWN WHAT TO A RESOURCE
THAT THEY I HAD TO USE TO
RESPOND TO FIRE AND FOR
HARDENING --
NONE OF THOSE ARE REIMBURSABLE
UNLESS THE P. U. C. SAYS SO IN A
FULL HEARING.
NONE OF IT IS REIMBURSABLE NONE
OF IT CAN BE PUT DOWN WHICH IS
GOING TO BE PUT IN THIS OTHER
CATEGORY --
AND I HAVE HERE ADAM SMITH
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON CAN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES THAT YOU
LIKE TO HAVE SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL.
BUT NOT WILL LOOK IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ADD THEIR SUPPORT AYE YES MISTER
CHAIR MIKE MONEY GOING TO HELP
THE COALITION CALIFORNIA UTILITY
EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING VALERIE TRABALHOS
PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY
SUPPORT.
KEPT HOUSE ES DE GENIE IN
THE OPPOSITION TO THE PORN GARB
ALTERNATIVE STRATEGY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK I TURN OPPOSES THIS
BILL%
AND BELIEVES THAT THE SEAVIEW
CRT HOUSE THAT HAS ALREADY
EXERCISED ITS AUTHORITY AND
DISCRETION.
BASED ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
FACTS UNDERLYING IT UTILITIES
OUR QUEST FOR WILD FOR EXPENSE
ACCOUNT.
AND THIS BILL TAKES AWAY THAT
DISCUSSION INTERNET URGE YOU DO
ALLOW THE CURRENT PROCESS TO
CONTINUE AND OPPOSE AYE AB.
TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX ARE THERE
ANYONE ELSE.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THIS RACE.
DR QUIRK --
IS YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON S. B. NINE OH ONE TO DEAL
WITH CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
IN YOUR BILL IT TALKS ABOUT
WILDFIRES BUT NOT CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES [inaudible]
BUT WHAT.
YOUR BILL TALKS ABOUT.
WILD FIRES AS AS OPPOSED TO
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IS THIS
FOR ALL TO ALL WHAT EXCITER ALL
WILDFIRES DOES NOT INTERACT WITH
NINE A ONE COMPLETELY SEPARATE.
NOW I KNOW WHY I'M JUST NOT. TO
STRESS THIS PARTICULAR ITEM.
LET'S LET'S SEE IF WE GET
CLARIFY CLARIFICATION ON WHETHER
IT'S ALL WILDFIRES WERE ALWAYS
SO WHY FIRES [inaudible]
OR BUT THAT'S THAT'S RIGHT YEAH
IT'S ALL WILDFIRES.
OKAY THE CLARIFICATION WOULD BE
ON PAGE THREE ONCE FOURTEEN TO
SIXTEEN IT IT SPECIFIES THE COST
RECOVERY AND THERE'S A GAP THERE
BECAUSE THE S. B. NINE OH ONE
COMP.
CREATES A NEW STANDARD OF REVIEW
FOR CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
RELATED AND IT SPECIFIED IN
SECTION. FOUR FIFTY ONE POINT
ONE AND FOUR FIFTY ONE POINT.
TWO AND SO YOU DON'T HAVE FOR
FIFTY ONE POINT.
ONE REFERENCE CHAIR WHICH IS THE
NEW STANDARD FOR CATASTROPHIC
FIRES.
YEAH CLIMBED SIXTEEN SECTION
FOUR REFERS TO FORTUNE FOR
FIFTEEN WHY BUT THE S. B. NINE
ONE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE REPORT
CREATES A NEW STANDARD FOR
CATASTROPHIC FIRES GOING
FORWARD.
SO THIS WOULD APPLY TO GENERAL
COST RECOVERY IT WOULD NOT APPLY
--
TO CUT CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOW CLASSIFIED
SEPARATELY AT THE PC WELL IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO ITS FINAL
MISSION IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT FATAL IT'S JUST A
CLARIFICATION OKAY.
KIND --
WE'RE CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
AMEND THE BILL NOW [inaudible]
EXITING.
ELOISE DID YOU HAVE A COKE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THIS BURKE GET AND FOR
CLARIFICATION NINE ONE HASN'T
PASSES COMMITTEE AT I OR THE
FORMER SO THERE'S NO REASON
[inaudible]
FORWARD.
NO NO WE'RE NOT SAYING HELPLESS
VIAWEEKLY EVIDENCES CLARIFYING
THE RECORD SO THAT.
THERE'S NO MISUNDERSTANDING FOR
WHICH I'M GRATEFUL DURING.
OKAY -- NO
OTHER COMMENTS THERE'S A MOTION
SECOND.
IT'S CALLED WORLD.
AB TWO TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX TO
PASS HOLDEN ARE.
HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
AND WHATEVER SIERRA.
MACE.
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AND NOT VOTING.
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE REYES.
REYES NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE PUTTING --
THE BILL HAS --
SIX IT'S ON HOME WE LOOK BACK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
Q. I WILL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE BUT IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO.
MURATSUCHI I THINK MAYBE HASN'T
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY GOES
.
WAS IT WHEN.
LET'S TAKE A ADD ON FOR WERE.
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT FOR MORE
MEMBERS TO TEXTURE SO.
LET'S LOOK GO BACK TO ITEM ONE
A. B. NINETEEN FOURTEEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON
CALDERON. NINETEEN FOURTEEN
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible]
HIS LIMIT.
OKAY -- MISS
FLOORS BILL IS OUT WITH ELEVEN
VOTES.
I WILL MOVE.
TO IT'S STILL.
WILL MOVE TO THE ON CALL BILL AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX QUIRK.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
PAY YOUR BILL WAS UP AND WILL
STAY HERE FOR TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU EVERYONE AND THANKS
FOR THE CLARIFICATION ON THE
BILL WILL TAKE A LOOK AT IT
BEFORE IT GOES TO THE FLOOR AND
MAKE SURE --
THAT THERE'S NO CONFLICTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BANKS
[inaudible]
OKAY
IT.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED